- [Voiceover] Hi Kim!
- [Voiceover] Hey Becca, so
what are talking about today?
- [Voiceover] Today we're
gonna be talking about how
a racial hierarchy was
established in the early Americas,
about the encomienda system,
the early Atlantic slave trade,
and how such an arbitrary
factor as race became a way
that our society was organized,
and we still feel the
effects of that today.
- [Voiceover] Okay, interesting.
- [Voiceover] So to begin we'll talk about
the encomienda system.
So the encomienda system was
this dependency relation system
that started in Spain and
was brought to the Americas
to control the labor system.
Encomienda, that actually
means entrust in Spanish,
Spaniards that were entrusted
with dividing up the labor
within the Native American populations.
So different encomenderos,
those were Spanish men that
were sent to the colonies,
were entrusted with dividing
up the labor between
different Native American groups.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so this
to me, it sounds a little bit
like a feudal system,
am I getting this right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, definitely!
- [Voiceover] So the feudal
system was this earlier
European Medieval system
where there'd be a lord
who would have the responsibility
of protecting serfs
and in response he'd get their labor
and a part of their wealth.
- [Voiceover] So this sounds
a lot like the encomenderos
and the Native Americans that
were in his jurisdiction.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] So the
encomenderos would offer
the Native Americans in
their colony protection
and they would also
offer them Catholicism.
They were under this kind of god, gold,
and glory motivation.
- [Voiceover] I think
I've heard of that before.
- [Voiceover] (chuckling)
Yeah, so god, gold, and glory
were some of the reasons
that colonists wanted to come
to the New World, and they
really wanted to inspire
and promote Catholicism abroad.
And they really wanted
to increase the practice
amongst the native people.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I think
one of the things that we
have to understand about this
time period is how religiously
motivated many people were.
I mean when it comes down
to it, gold is gonna be more
of a motivator than religion
but they saw their role
as Christians, as Catholics,
as trying to convert the entire world.
- [Voiceover] Right, and
in return the encomenderos
expected from the native
people a lot of labor.
So the natives had a
much better understanding
of the land itself that they
were aiming to cultivate.
At the time period in
the 1500s, the Spaniards,
the Portuguese, the Dutch, the English,
everyone's coming over and
wanting to create new markets,
especially with tobacco, sugar,
and the Native Americans
under the encomienda system
were expected to help
the encomenderos produce
at a really high rate in
which they they could send
these goods back to Europe.
- [Voiceover] I think it's
worthwhile to note here
that we're saying, oh
they wanted the labor
of the Native Americans.
Well why didn't the Spanish
just send their own people
to process sugar, to grow
tobacco up in the New World?
And there are a couple
of reasons for that.
One is that they kind of
knew that the New World
was more or less a death trap.
(laughter)
It wouldn't be until the mid-1600s
that a lot of these
places had a survival rate
for settlers above 50%.
So a lot of whites in
Europe wanted to avoid that.
They also didn't really
see these plantations
as being something they
needed to work directly.
They kind of thought, I would
rather stay in the courts
of Europe, I would rather be a lord.
You know, many in England,
later they'll be many members
of Parliament who own
plantations in the West Indies
and they've never even
been to those plantations
but they're sure profiting.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I think
that's definitely right.
And when the encomienda system
was more officially instated
with Nicolas de Ovando in 1502,
that was the first
official encomienda system
in the West Indies.
He actually took over
after Columbus was ousted
from his role in San Salvador.
- [Voiceover] Why was Columbus ousted?
- [Voiceover] He was a really bad leader.
Ovando really took over
the encomienda system
and then it started to
look a lot more like
what we would call slavery.
So slowly the encomenderos
would no longer offer
the Native Americans protection,
but instead threatened
them if they did not
reach their quota.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
instead of protection
they get threats.
- [Voiceover] And oftentimes
that turned into extreme
punishment or death, and
they were forced to do
extremely hard labor.
So sowing a sugar
plantation is not easy work
and so they expected extreme amounts
of hard labor in the hot sun.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, processing
sugar is like a 24 hour a day
kind of deal and it is I
think perhaps the worst
kind of labor you could do.
- [Voiceover] And they
weren't just trying to promote
Catholicism but also
stripping Native Americans
of their culture and of
their religious practices.
- [Voiceover] So Catholicism,
not optional. (chuckling)
- [Voiceover] Catholicism was not,
not something they were offering,
it was something they were
instituting with force.
So as more conquistadores
come over to the West Indies,
some notice this does look like slavery,
and we are not treating
the Native American people
with dignity or really as humans at all.
Bartolome de las Casas was an encomendero
but in kind of the mid-1500s
he came over to actually
see his encomiendas in practice,
and realized the inhumane
treatment and abuse
the encomienda system promoted.
He released his encomienda
and started to dedicate
his life to petitioning and
lobbying the King of Spain,
Charles V, to institute
new laws that would protect
Native Americans against
these abusive practices.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, you know
when you're looking around
this time period for a
good person in this system,
Bartolome de las Casas is
pretty much the only one.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, he was
a good dude amongst a lot
of not so good dudes.
(laughter)
And so in 1542 new laws,
they were literally called
the New Laws, were passed by Charles V.
And these laws didn't outlaw
the encomienda system,
but aimed to put some regulation
on these inhumane practices.
The encomienda system wouldn't be
outlawed completely until 1720.
- [Voiceover] Oh, wow.
- [Voiceover] So the effects
of the encomienda system
were already really
being felt at this time
and contributed to the
formation of this arbitrary
racial hierarchy that we
will continue to talk about
in the next video.